foreign
[Music]
does it really matter I don't think
anyone's gonna watch it
right just okay me myself talk to the
camera yep okay
yep yep
welcome new recruits to Stargate command
this is your health and safety induction
just to briefly introduce myself I'm the
health and safety officer here at
Cheyenne Mountain I am going to be
responsible to trying to help you to
stay safe while doing your job here at
Stargate command
good look at that
never seen a higher turnover rate of
stuff in my life yes okay sorry right
so
welcome to Stargate command the most
exciting adventure of your military
career here at the SGC you will
encounter wonders like you have never
imagined that will mostly try to kill
you
and but with these amazing
yes but
but with these amazing opportunities
also comes some risks
alien technology they'll probably try
and kill you on everyone else on the
planet
with that in mind there are some health
and safety policies and procedures that
I'd like to discuss with you during this
induction period that you will 100
ignore there will of course be dangers
that we cannot foresee
every day apparently
and because all the health and safety
policies are ignored
the entire basis but at risk almost
every single day by the way they're
going to know this is a green screen
yes I know that real gate room has been
shot up again but it's very clearly
agreed okay
um yes policies and procedures that SG-1
more constantly but right okay if you
are able to follow the health and safety
risk assessments and policies and
procedure laid out I'm certain that we
can minimize the risk while maximizing
the adventure as you are aware you may
come in contact with many alien races
while on missions I hope none of them
are afraid of giant mechanical spiders
arachnophobia
uh sorry yes okay right
most of friendly should be treated with
respect
most of those races are friendly and
should be treated with honesty and open
respect some others not so much though
right
by the way if any of your mates start
acting weird or their eyes glow it's
because they've been taken over by a
snakehead alien or or they're not
themselves at all they might be a
completely different alien race this
Brown thing that could like
holographically project them or
something so if anybody of your mates
start acting weird basically probably
best is to shoot them and meet them no
okay it's probably best to report it to
the proper authorities
shoot them
um we've got a risk assessment for it
though so don't worry just go and check
that out wear a collar so some aliens
however are a risk to yourselves and
your colleagues and the entire planet
yeah okay right
um
every living thing on the planet in fact
a lot of the time
yeah I mean one of these alien species
that apparently they we're telling these
guys to respect and honor was actually
physically Satan how come nobody seemed
bothered by that he's he's Satan
uh-uh yes yes yes fine to keep yourself
and your colleagues safe we ask you to
please follow the health and safety
procedures and policies laid out in the
manual provided during your induction
period I ask you to please read all of
these policies they're not going to I
might even I've written the risk
assessments nobody signed them
and suck it
we ask you to please follow these safety
policies and procedures please read
through all of the risk assessments that
I've painstakingly written to try to
help you state that sorry I couldn't
even get through that because I I get
I'm going to read
honestly it's like most of these guys
actually go looking for danger it's like
they sort of run in go oh look there's
some alien technology let's play with it
like it's a freaking kid's toy and then
just bring it back to the base and it'll
yeah if you have any questions or
worries about the risks involved in
working at Stargate command my door is
always open it is always open because
the last Alien Invasion destroyed it I
still haven't got a new one
okay
my door is always open I am there for
you please come and talk to me and if
you have any issues I'm more than
willing to discuss them they've nobody's
ever walked through my door that nobody
cares okay
maybe this fresh batch will last a
little bit longer than the last ones so
we should really be concerned about the
death rate current Link in this base I
mean as nobody noticed that an awful lot
of American soldiers are suddenly dying
and there's no reason for it all getting
horribly injured
quite a few
I mean
the last Invasion how many people lost
their lives in that last one that
foothold thing
you know I don't know
I think somebody really should have
noticed by now let's let's hope that
none of these you know soldiers families
speak to each other
yes okay
please ensure that you have read signed
and agreed all of the risk Assessments
in your induction pack
we are here to help you stay safe while
you're on your adventures through the
Stargate no I can't I can't do it
most of these kids have no clue what
they're walking into they're just they
were soldiers a week ago and now they're
going to be bouncing around through a
bloody Stargate that and even if you're
not one of the SG teams
it's not safe to even be a secretary in
this space
I mean I thought the worst of it was the
snake thing you know we do risk
assessment for wear a collar or whatever
um but I thought that was always for at
least their eyes glow so you could tell
it was them these new aliens you don't
even know it's that I mean
you have to play 20 Questions with them
to try and figure out whether it's them
or not and even then it was difficult I
mean
how do I write a risk assessment for
that nonsense
or they come back and they're not really
them they're robots or something I mean
it's just
how many times is that going to happen
until we try to decide to do something
about it I don't know
I mean if if we're going to do this
induction video we may as well do it
honestly don't we I mean these guys
they've known freaking clue what they're
walking into so here we go an honest
induction video when you go through the
gate don't touch anything
if it's even remotely shiny or even if
it just looks like a freaking Rock I'll
leave it alone because it will almost
certainly try to kill everybody and if
it doesn't try to kill everybody it will
do something or it'll swap your body
with somebody else or something else
just don't do it if anything even
remotely looks out of place run away
don't walk run if you see a mechanical
spider or anything that's even remotely
even if it doesn't try to attack you
kill it immediately if your mate acts
even remotely weird shoot him in the
freaking head immediately I mean I would
even say if you even got your like
middle name wrong or something
shoot him in the head I I seriously
don't mess around if you're mate
remotely says I don't know goes off his
food for five minutes shoot him in the
head I actually genuinely think we
should have a shoot first and ask
questions later policy in all aspects of
life
I mean everything a guy comes in and
goes all of a sudden has rice pudding
you've never seen him adverse pudding
before shoot him in the head because
chances are he's probably an alien
I mean it's it's getting to the point
where you cannot trust anything so just
don't
other thing when you go through the gate
and doesn't say anything happens even a
remotely strange if it makes you sort of
go hmm run back to the gate and jump
your ass through don't don't wait to
investigate because almost every time
you people investigate something we
nearly all get killed
don't I mean explore have a poke around
and the second it gets weird run away
that would be an honest
that would be an honest induction video
that would actually be an honest health
and safety induction video to keep us
all safe
don't touch anything if it looks weird
run away or shoot it in the head that
that's how this
key to this script keeps the script
stupid the script's gonna get us all
killed
[Music]